hey guys there's one more thing I need
to talk about before I can describe the
vectorized form for the quadratic
approximation of multivariable functions
which is a mouthful to say so let's say
you have some kind of expression that
looks like a times x squared and I'm
thinking of X as a variable times B
times XY Y is another variable plus C
times y squared and I'm thinking of a b
and c is being constants and x and y as
being variables now this kind of
expression has a fancy name it's called
a quadratic form quadratic form and that
always threw me off i always kind of
like what what does form mean you know i
know what a quadratic expression is in
quadratic typically means something is
squared or you have two variables but
why do they call it a form and basically
it just means that the only things in
here are quadratic you know it's not the
case that you have like an X term
sitting on its own or like a constant
out here like 2 and you're adding all of
those together instead it's just you
have purely quadratic terms but of
course mathematicians don't want to call
it just a purely quadratic expression
instead they have to give a fancy name
to things so that it seems more
intimidating than it needs to be but
anyway so we have a quadratic form and
the question is how can we express this
in a vectorized sense and for analogy
let's think about linear terms where
let's say you have a times X plus B
times y and I'll throw another variable
in there another constant times another
variable Z if you see something like
this where every variable is just being
multiplied by a constant and then you
add terms like that to each other we can
express this nicely with vectors where
you pile all of the constants into their
own vector a vector containing a B and C
and you imagine the dot product between
that and a vector that contains all of
the variable components XY and Z and the
convenience here is then you can have
just a symbol like a V let's say which
represents this whole constant vector
and then you can write down take the dot
product between that and then have
another another symbol maybe a
bold-faced X which represents a vector
that contains all of the variables and
this way your notation just kind of
looks like a constant times a variable
just like in the single variable world
when you have a constant number times a
variable number it's kind of like taking
a constant vector times a variable
vector and the importance of writing
things down like this is that V could be
a vector that contains not just three
numbers but like
hundred numbers and then X would have a
hundred corresponding variables and the
notation doesn't become any more
complicated it's generalizable to higher
dimensions so the question is can we do
something similar like that with our
quadratic form because you can imagine
let's say we started introducing the
variable Z then you would have to have
some other term you know some other
constant times the X z quadratic term
and then some other constant times the Z
squared quadratic term and another one
for the Y Z quadratic term and we get
out of hand and as soon as you start
introducing things like 100 variables it
would get seriously out of hand because
there's a lot of different quadratic
terms so we want a nice way to express
this and I'm just going to kind of show
you how we do it and then we'll work it
through to see why it makes sense so
usually instead of thinking of B times X
Y we we actually think of this as 2
times some constant times X Y and this
of course doesn't make a difference you
would just change what B represents but
you'll see why it's more convenient to
write it this way in just a moment so
the vectorized way to describe a
quadratic form like this is to take a
matrix a two-by-two matrix since this is
two dimensions where a and C are in the
diagonal and then B is on the other
diagonal and we always think of these as
being symmetric matrices so if you
imagine kind of reflecting the whole
matrix about this line you'll get the
same numbers so it's important that we
have have that kind of symmetry and now
what you do is you multiply the vector
the variable vector that's got XY on the
right side of this matrix and then you
multiply it again
but you kind of you turn it on its side
so instead of being a vertical vector
you transpose it to being a horizontal
vector on the other side and this is a
little bit analogous to you know having
two variables multiplied in you have two
vectors multiplied in but on either side
and this is a good point by the way if
you are uncomfortable with matrix
multiplication to maybe pause the video
go find the videos about matrix
multiplication and kind of refresh or
learn about that because moving forward
I'm just going to assume that it's
something you're familiar with
so going about computing this first
let's tackle this right multiplication
here we have a matrix multiplied by a
vector well the first component that we
get we're going to multiply the top row
by each corresponding term in the vector
so it'll be a times X a times X plus B
times y
plus B times that second term y and then
similarly for the bottom term we'll take
the bottom row and multiply the
corresponding term so B times X B times
X plus C times y C times y so that's
what it looks like when we do that right
multiplication and of course we've got
to keep our transposed vector over there
on the right on the left side so now we
have this is just a two by one vector
now and this is a one by two you could
think of it as a horizontal vector or a
you know one by two matrix but now when
we multiply these guys you just kind of
line up the corresponding terms you'll
have X multiplied by that entire top
expression so X multiplied by ax plus B
Y a X plus B Y and then we add that to
the second term Y multiplied by the
second term of this guy which is BX plus
C Y so Y multiplied by B X plus C Y and
all of these are numbers so we can
simplify it once we start distributing
the first term is x times a times X so
that's a x squared and then the next
term is x times B times y so that's B
times X Y over here we have Y times B
times X so that's the same thing as B
times X Y so that's kind of why we have
why it's convenient to write a 2 there
because that naturally comes out of our
expansion and then the last term is y
times C times y so that's C Y squared so
we get back the original quadratic form
that we were shooting for
you know ax squared plus 2b XY plus C Y
squared that's how this entire term
expands as you kind of work it through
you end up with the same quadratic
expression now the convenience of this
this quadratic form being written with a
matrix like this is if we can write this
more abstractly and instead of writing
the whole matrix in you could just let a
letter like M represent that whole
matrix and then take the vector that
represents the variable may be like a
bold-faced X and you would multiply it
on the right and then you transpose it
and multiply it on the left so typically
you denote that by putting a little T as
a superscript so X transpose
multiplied by the matrix from the left
and this expression this is what a
quadratic form looks like in vectorized
form and the convenience is the same as
it was in the linear case just like v
could represent something that had a
hundred different numbers in it and X
would have a hundred different constants
you could do something similar here
where you can write that same expression
even if the matrix M is super huge let's
just see what this would look like in a
three dimensional circumstance so uh
actually I'll need more room so I'll go
down even further so we have X transpose
multiplied by the matrix multiplied by X
bold-faced X and let's say instead this
represented you know you have X then Y
then Z our transpose vector and then our
matrix our matrix let's say it was a b c
d e f and because it needs to be
symmetric whatever term is in this spot
here needs to be the same as over here
kind of when you reflect it about that
diagonal similarly see that's going to
be the same term here and e would be
over here so there's only really six
free terms that you have but it fills up
this entire matrix and then on the right
side we would multiply that by x y z now
i won't work it out in this video now
but you can imagine actually multiplying
this matrix by this vector and then
multiplying the corresponding vector
that you get by this transpose vector
and you'll get some kind of quadratic
form with three variables and the point
is you'll get a very complicated one but
it's very simple to express things like
this so with that tool in hand in the
next video I will talk about how we can
use this notation to express the
quadratic approximations for multi
variable functions see you then